je m'appelle marie blum
vous savez qui je suis j'ai lu l'acte
d'accusation après votre appel hier soir
puis j'ai acheté votre livre vous
comprenez que vous êtes accusé d'avoir
tenu une maison de jeu illégale vous
accepté de me défendre pas que
j'arriverais à convaincre mes associés
de jouer gros avec la princesse du poker
si vous croyez qu'une princesse peut
faire ce que j'ai fait vous vous trompez
je sais que vous avez une piètre opinion
de moi mais qu'est ce que vous diriez si
toutes vos informations et vos préjugés
simpliste sur moi et fo se met pas très
ceci est une histoire vraie mais j'ai
changé tous les noms à part le maire et
les mollets la partie de poker
hebdomadaire des ménages aux cobras j'ai
besoin de ton aide
je côtoyais des vedettes de cinéma des
réalisateurs et de puissants hommes
d'affaires
il risque est tout tout le temps merci
mali tiens c'est pour toi merci beaucoup
je vais arrêter de payer en tant
qu'assistant de la part non je vais
seulement arrêter de te payer sur soi de
l'argent chaque semaine pendant la
partie je trouve pas ça juste qui va
arrêter de me payer parce que je gagne
trop d'argent dans mon deuxième emploi
ici je dis non je vais perdre les deux
emplois parce que toi tu trouves pas ça
juste et pas en position de négocier je
peux te remplacer n'importe quand tu
sais combien de sources hier ils ont
brûlé à solesmes combien aucune ils
brûlaient pas les sorcières c'est un
mythe il dépend des face à mon
impuissance l'humiliation avait fait
place à une profonde colère
il me fallait un clan et vite
j'organiserai une partie dans cette
suite tous les mardis soirs droit
d'entrée 250 millions ça va faire jaser
ça alors on joue
vous avez passé huit ans à haut niveau
des deux ans à new york à la tête du
plus sélect et du puits des cas dans des
repaires masculin vous avez lu les
autres noms sur l'acte d'accusation
allant molly à quel point tu y es vois
impliquées dans la mafia russe il est
trop exposé à 2.8 millions en
circulation dans les rues en ce moment
tu vas te faire prendre vous avez mis
sur pied une société de plusieurs
millions de dollars presque uniquement
grâce à votre intelligence est mise en
accusation par la cour fédérale de la
personne n'est parfait
il y à une nouvelle offre sur la table
l'immunité absolue en échange des
disques durs vous avez vu ce qu'ils
contiennent il y a de quoi briser des
vies des familles des carrières pourquoi
vous vous battez tout seul où sont les
gens que vous protéger en cachant des
bouts d'histoires
je leur dirai tout ce qu'ils veulent
savoir sur moi sur mois seulement et
c'est tout